far from the front line
but not far enough a makeshift shrine
in a residential district of ganja
a community torn apart
they were my friends and close
acquaintances you can't grasp
just how much my heart is bleeding
at least 13 people died here in
azerbaijan's second biggest city on
saturday baku accuses armenia of
launching the attack
death and despair in nagorno-karabash
too
the ceasefire announced by the two sides
after saturday's deadly attack in ganja
proved short-lived
and fighting resumed soon afterwards
the disputed region has been controlled
by separatist ethnic armenians since
1994
but it remains an internationally
recognised part of azerbaijan
armenia denies any involvement in the
ganger attack
and accuses baku of continuing to shell
heavily populated areas
inside nagorno-karabash
this man in shusha says these are azeri
rockets
we are respecting the ceasefire but are
the azerbaijanis respecting it
where is the ceasefire look they are
firing shusha is full of these rockets
this is prohibited ammunition
as tensions between azerbaijan and
armenia escalate
fears are growing that russia and turkey
could be drawn into a regional war
[Music]
well let's bring in dw's yulia han who's
in ganja azerbaijan's
second city yulia once again the
ceasefire between armenia and azerbaijan
has been
broken what more can you tell us
the fighting has continued despite a new
ceasefire agreement despite calls from
around the world to stop
instead what we're seeing is once again
azerbaijan
and armenia blaming each other for
breaching that deal
i'm in ganja right now azerbaijan's
second largest city it's home to more
than 300
000 people a missile leveled
several homes in this residential area
on
saturday we have been showing
these pictures already and that actually
happened before
the new truce came into effect now what
you can see right behind me
are several two-story buildings what
used to be
two-story buildings but they have all
been reduced to rubble
at least 13 people were killed in this
attack according
to the official figures including two
children a teenage girl
and a baby girl and while authorities
both in armenia and here in azerbaijan
are denying deliberately targeting
civilians
residential areas like this one have
come under
increasing shelling even here in ganja
which is far away
from the front line but it shows that
civilians here are paying a very heavy
price for this war
in any armed conflict louis julie of
course it's very difficult to
confirm to verify claims made by the two
warring sides what's your experience in
this conflict
well we are not moving around here
independently
we have been given access by the
authorities here in azerbaijan they
allowed us to come here
to report on this conflict they set up
an infrastructure for media for
international journalists to cover this
crisis to cover
their side of the conflict we have been
assigned a driver and a contact
affiliated with
the government they are always with us
wherever
we go they say it's for our own safety
and security but at the same time it of
course
limits what we can hear see and report
on
well for decades armenia and azerbaijan
have been have been in this frozen
conflict over nagorno-karabakh
it's been mainly frozen but now it's
flared up again we're seeing fighting
are people there
were that you're talking to are they
concerned that this could
flare up into an all-out war again
well yes we've been talking to people
here in ganja today
from time to time time people would come
here to pay their respects
to those who were killed or to search
for some of their belongings these
people
are clearly visibly still under shock
there is
pain there is grief but there is also a
lot of anger
people here are openly blaming the
armenian military
for deliberately targeting targeting
civilians
and they say they expect their
government to retaliate now
add to that the history decades of
mistrust between
the two countries and there's also
um no sign of backing down on the
political
level many people here tell me that they
see nagorno-karabakh
as a part of land that rightfully
belongs to
azerbaijan that has belonged to
azerbaijan for
the past nearly 30 years and for them
this is the moment to retake this part
of land so
from where i'm standing right now it
doesn't look like that the
new ceasefire agreement is going to turn
things
into a more peaceful direction julia
thank you very much that was dws yulia
han there reporting from ganja
azerbaijan second city
you